bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi dio sono parigi e e non ho avviato
la musica di mortacci mia ora tutti
ragazzi benvenuti questo lo video sono
farisei e ce l'ho fatta ad avviare la
musica una cosa devo fare prima di
avviare i blog non ce la faccio mai
sono un genio 4 e il primo blog che li
faccio in casa mia che era da un secolo
che ormai non lo facevo qua niente
ragazzi sono un miliardo di cose che
devo dire quindi prima che il blog tour
i secoli partiamo dalla frana della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da ruta che ha fatto questo
disegno quelli ragazzi allora io quello
sono io in versione anime la prima volta
che ho visto questo disegno stavo per
piangere bene di passare alle news
ragazzi perché c'è un miliardo di robe
da dire la prima cosa la più importante
in assoluto
quanti di voi sanno che io praticamente
ogni anno faccio una live una live nella
quale gioco in diretta con voi tutto il
pomeriggio e la trasmetto sul mio canale
di youtube lo faccio una volta l'anno la
rai ragazzi e domani per chi volesse
partecipare a giocare con me apparire
nella live che sarà in diretta domani
alle 4 quindi chi vola vuole vedere
domani che domenica dalle quattro in poi
ci sarà la live si connetta sul canale
che giocherò con voi in diretta tutto il
pomeriggio e chi invece volesse
partecipare quindi apparire nel video e
giocare con me domani i giochi che farò
con voi sono due e sono in descrizione
quindi potete trovare nella descrizione
di questo video se volete partecipare
alla ii domani registrate vicoli link
qui sotto al sito pass che vi fa
scaricare quel gioco così domani già lo
avete potete giocare con me poi non dite
che non ve l'avevo detto perché motivi
per ferie non lo sapevo l'ho detto io
domani non mi venivano non produco yuna
khedira gazzoli sono tornato nella mia
regia 20 metri quadri diciamo che in
questa settimana comunque sono successe
un paio di cose divertenti una persona
mi ha fermato un signore non mi ricordo
e mi ha riconosciuta ma detto dio tu sei
falli jeio mio sul mio figlio ti segue
un sacchismo praticamente questo
ragazzino che mi segue dove partirà un
mio raduno mi ha detto il papa sono che
non era riuscito a venire allora ho
detto che questa è una cosa che avevo
mai fatto però ho detto andiamo a fargli
una sorpresa a casa
della serie andiamo a suonarli al
campanello così apre la porta e mi trova
lì sembrava un'idea carina quindi ho
voluto riprendere la cosa vi lascio il
pizzo barche epico credetemi ma si
guarda dall'occhiello non voglio che mi
veda ma è qui ma è nudo era nudo nudo
vista ma minuto abbiamo capito che non
c'era tra viso ma gesù cristo poteva
proprio spremuto in quel momento ai
arduino come fai a programmare su arduin
come vai e saper programmare su arduino
non è possibile
in attacco il thun 4 dovrebbe sorpresa
riuscita più o meno
e viene da pensare ma se io che una
volta ho provato a suonare il campanello
e mi è capitato che mi aprissero nudi ma
chi fa i testimoni di geova che in
genere suona le porte delle vecchie e
mai capito che la vecchia fosse
andiamo avanti ragazzi sono stato
chiamato da focus junior che è un focus
junior e un giorno una cosa che leggevo
io da piccolo quando ero piccolo mi
hanno chiesto di fare un'intervista da
loro ed è stata l'intervista particolare
perché hanno chiamato una decina di
ragazzini e gli hanno chiesto di fare
un'intervista loro a me perché poi
sarebbe andata sul giornale ho chiesto
di registrare una cosa perché sarebbe
stato epico e quindi ragazzi state per
vedere il primo fa risponde in live
della storia che non ho mai registrato
un fare risponde in live
ma questo è stato veramente figo quindi
dovevo registrarlo assolutamente bene
tanto mi capita però in giro da grillo
applicato quando inizio a vedere uno che
riguarda la montagna fa male perché alla
fine sono mi sento in giudizio poi
quando succede mi piace viaggiare un sa
chi vorrei visitare anche tu col
giappone ma che non è il giappone non è
giappone il giappone nati paesino in
provincia di como
e questo era poi il motivo intenti borsa
preferita è la vera domanda non
bellissima quella della scimmia che fa
così e bella quella carità e con le
lacrime il cuore però non quello rosso
roma 16 kant e li fa schifo quello più
lungo delle mani uno blu non è se ci
credi di essere cambiato effetto
catanesi siamo no dal punto di vista del
carattere nobel o di di sicurezza
interiore sempre lasciato ad operare ad
essere un'occasione per conoscere i fan
di persone questo non è perché ci siete
voi ad evocarla in ticino e mi piace un
sacco conoscere persone che mi seguono
di persone
pensavate fosse finita qui in realtà i
ragazzini sempre dopo l'intervista hanno
preparato una specie di quiz
mi hanno detto fai ti facciamo delle
domande sulle cose che studiamo noi e
quindi mi hanno fatto nelle domande in
base a quello che stanno studiando la
cosa non è facile perché quando vi si
chiede ad esempio cose di analisi
grammaticale che io facevo le elementari
ora che ho finito le superiori
non mi ricordo più cazzo quindi alcune
cose sono state difficilissime da
ricordava che quindi mi hanno fatto
delle domande e io ho tentato di
rispondere sarebbe potuto andare molto
peggio che vedete allora questo piano ed
un'altra di italiano italiana nella
città di palermo
[Musica]
vabbè magari questa domanda perché vedo
cambiato
questa tecnica personale e quello che
riesci anche loro figura e 7 abbiamo una
di musica attuale dai ce l'abbiamo solo
coi capelli simile tuo sito
magari c'è stata proficua
non so del ponte che non ti video
sbatterti così a pensare e due materie
nella mia vita hanno fatto latino e
filosofia non son cazzo delle due sedi
regazzoli scusatemi se stavolta non
faccio lo svantaggio dei pacchi perché
sono arrivato da poco a casa e quindi ho
pochi pacchi in giro che brutta frase
questa l'altro per tutto il video
gesticolato tipo una formica però fate
finta di niente
ricordatevi per domani per chi volesse
partecipare alla live giocare come i
link sono in descrizione non lo dirò più
poi non dite che non ve l'avevo detto
prima di concludere ragazzi possono fare
domanda al affari domanda di oggi è come
l'altra materia con la quale non ho mai
avuto a che fare e appunto latino va
temi una favi domanda a vostra scelta in
latino e dovrò rispondere come dio mio
no ci sarà un traduttore di latino
promesso non userò traduzioni robe
proverò a tradurla io finire gazzoli
spero che i video vi sia piaciuto e cosa
vede più stato giusto quindi ammanco
l'italiano figurati il latino cioè senza
video è piaciuta la sua trattamento è un
mi piace anche a faccia di facebook e
condivido a trattare descrizione ave
cesare morituri te salutant
e noi ci vediamo al prossimo video ave
cesare morituri te salutant vuol dire se
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e
noi ci rivediamo